welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
we're back with another edition of the
early on in recruitment series where
we're sitting down with recruiters who
are early on in their recruitment
journey to find out what they've learned
along the way so far the challenges that
they're working through advice for those
that
also early on in their recruitment
career and even advice for people that
are wanting to enter the recruitment
industry as well really excited to be
joined by katie and jamie today from
storm two so before we start uncovering
their journey and i've got loads of
questions to ask
if you could both introduce yourself
katie i'll come to you first and we'll
go from there
yeah so i'm katie i've been
in recruitment for about 10 months now i
graduated last year and really enjoying
it
i love that
jamie
yeah i'm jamie i'm
been in recruitment now for two years i
graduated back in 2019 from strathclyde
in glasgow and uh yeah i'm now one of
the managers here at storm 2 and we
specialize in fintech specific
recruitment so katie and i both
run
teams within the engineering side of the
business as well so specializing in
software positions
software positions in the fintech world
in the center yeah yeah i love that okay
so where where are always like to start
is i'll jaime i'll come to you first
like
how how did you end up obviously
graduating in glasgow did you say yeah
and end up working in recruitment in
london like how the hell did that happen
yeah i think like most to be honest it
wasn't uh something i was particularly
looking out for um i actually had a job
to do wealth management in dubai and
then could have got cold feet at the
last second uh really also it was like
that de veer group yeah what it was the
viewer group yeah yeah like so it's so
important yeah it's very infamous yeah
you're going on like no salary at all
yeah yeah fair enough yeah so um yeah i
was reached out to my headhunter down
here and thought yeah why not let's go
down uh see what they have to say and
ended up interviewing with quite a few
different recruitment businesses around
london uh can i get a feel for it i
really didn't know too much about
recruitment at all um
obviously the stories but not not really
the ins and outs of it and uh yeah i
really just enjoyed hearing all the
founders different stories and things
and started getting more and more
engaged and then uh yeah basically in
the end went with the
the ceo and the and uh leadership team
that i you know believed in the story
the most of and thought you know these
guys really are ambitious they want to
get somewhere and i thought yeah why not
let's let's commit to it and move down
yeah
okay okay before i ask you the same
thing i guess just interested jamie like
as you went on that journey of like oh
recruitment like what is this blah blah
blah like i guess what as you were going
through that what got you most excited
about it so clearly you you'd been
thinking about sales it seems like if
you were gonna i know wealth
management's a bit different yeah that
would involve sales but like what what
ended up getting you i guess quite
excited or that you maybe learnt in that
sort of journey that you least that
maybe you didn't expect
yeah i think it was the
the way they were selling the organic
growth opportunities to me i'm a pretty
ambitious guy
i want to like you know do really well
really quickly and i love the idea of it
being a sort of meritocracy based
environment where you really get about
what you put in i think that was the
thing that really engaged me from from
day one um and then yeah i mean storm
two the promotion structure they kind of
sold to us seems kind of unrivalled in
the market um so you know that that's
kind of was one of my main um checking
points from
you know yeah nice
yeah
so katie what about you so she graduated
more recently how did you find
recruitment is there a story there
yeah so i actually graduated from the
university of manchester and i did a
physical geography degree
so it was all i was just learning about
rivers
very scientific but i read it yeah i
really didn't want to go into that and
one of my friends did recruitment and it
just sounded really really fun to be
honest i'm quite competitive so i used
to do loads of sports and i just thought
it might be
something really interesting
okay so curious is it he or she your
friend
he
how did he sell it to you out of
interest
uh it was really it was really about the
money to be honest
yeah just doing really well and and the
career progression as well i think he
didn't go to uni but he he was already
leading a team within like two years so
that was really the main reason fair
enough so
so the next question i have for both uk
i'll come to you first is like it's
obviously obviously still early on in
this journey but obviously would have
had assumptions and sort of i guess um
things that you would have thought about
that recruitment would have given you
skills or experience but always
interested to find out what what skills
or experience do you think recruitment
has given you that you least expected so
far do you think
i think it's given me a lot more
confidence to be honest because i've
just graduated uni and i'm speaking to
like loads of members of the c-suite in
big fintechs in the states and
you to win business you have to be
confident don't you have to be confident
in what you're selling and and what
you're talking about as well so that's i
think that's probably the main thing
and what and what do you feel like
that's that's also then
that confidence also shown up in not
just your professional life but personal
life
yeah yeah i think so yeah i love that
that's amazing so quickly on that before
i come to you german the same question
i guess just talk to us a bit about
obviously i'm sure you wasn't um
as confident as you are now from the
very beginning i guess
what were some of the things that helped
you cultivate that confidence out of
interest to speak to those types of
people that you that you just mentioned
i think really the the only thing is
practice to be honest
yeah i think obviously um reading around
fintech learning a bit more about it and
then as jamie said we're in the
engineering vertical so i didn't know
anything about engineering but yeah
reading about it talking to candidates
and also like learning from the
directors and jc as well
okay fair enough so just really i guess
just go out of your way to learn as much
as possible so you do have exactly yeah
more context yeah fair enough
jamie so what about you then so far
obviously you've been in recruitment a
bit longer but like what obviously
clearly you felt like you had an idea in
your head of what recruitment would have
given you what you hoped it would but
like what skills or experience you think
it's given you that you least expected
so far yeah i definitely reiterate the
confidence piece because i've really
through uni i'd save my one of my
biggest weaknesses was like presenting i
didn't really like the the kind of
public speaking element to yeah yeah
like quite a confident guy with my
friends group but when it comes to
public speaking just understand it and
um yeah i mean
there's a lot of situations here where
you know we're meeting as kitty said c
suite of businesses that are you know
really really accomplished people i
remember um six months and we went over
to to stockholm and i basically had to
go around and meet loads of ceos by
myself and sit down and
confidently speak about the business and
pitch to them you know six months out of
unity and it is that you know it comes
back to that imposter syndrome type
thing
you're thinking you know
what what are the justifications for me
sitting in front of you guys
fetching a business i've only been in
for five months but no it really is
confidence is a big player uh and then
the other things i think that i've
massively
um
learned from is the keeping my emotions
in control i mean it's something there's
a lot of a lot of elements in
recruitment where things might not go
your way or you know candidates people
are very tricky uh you know objects to
deal with and there's lots of things you
know in in play and uh being able to be
kind of patient on that side
and not be too affected personally by
things that are outside of your control
is definitely something i've benefited
from or yeah
you definitely go through that a lot in
the beginning like
yeah if there's a obviously you could
you really sort of when you're doing
those deals or the first couple of deals
you're like really at that high but and
then when things go wrong you can be
quite really low it's you just get
better at staying a bit more grounded
and sort of not being too high with the
highs and too low the lows but um i have
to ask you jamin and katy feel free to
chip in after but
like i've spoken to a lot of recruiters
that even
two years a year down the line like they
really struggle with what you just
described there like that justification
of like who am i to be sitting down with
these people and to be talking about why
they should be using our service or
working with us
so i guess
to i guess would you mind just talking
to us a bit about like
i don't know what comes up for me is i
feel like there's no alternative besides
like just owning that do you know what i
mean like yeah i don't think you're
going to get very far by trying to
pretend you've got more than five months
experience and you have do you know what
i mean like how did you work
through that besides just getting
yourself in those situations and i guess
just learning and how you could have
done better in that last situation but
like how did you just work through that
because a lot of people struggle with
that and i hear that a lot
yeah
yeah i think my process for it was two
two different things one is i think you
really do need to believe in what you're
selling unlike yeah creating a way that
you can really believe and get behind
what what you're trying to you know
pitch to to these people and secondly um
i can't remember who it was that that
you know gave me this idea but basically
to treat any of these c-suite or really
senior people as if they your your best
friend's mom and dad because ultimately
it could be your best friend's mom and
dad and how
how you how you speak to them is how you
know how you should be speaking to these
people they'll probably treat you the
same with the same level of respect if
you you know approach it like that and
that was something that just kind of
settled a few nerves uh
the first few you know conversations i
had
but did you like just curious like did
you like address like did you just
address it did you say did you like own
the fact that like look we're a storm to
the we have a big plan this is what we
believe in
i've been working the business for this
time like did you own that because i
think sometimes people get rid of like
did i do i try and like be perceived
i've got more experience than i had or
whatever i don't know did how did you
approach that yeah i think it's yeah we
were more selling like these ambitions
we want to do rather than this is the
short five months stunt i have done yeah
yeah and they yeah trying to get them
bought into that rather than what you
have already accomplished because at
that point you know we'd you know just
started adding our first set of contacts
to the system and things i mean
if we were if we were trying to sell
them on that i don't think we got very
far
yeah yeah fair enough katie what about
you have you have how did you
process this or approach this because
this is a really common challenge that
people go through
yeah oh i i think i can't really add too
much more than than jamie has but i
think it is just
it's just something that you learn over
time to be honest that it gets easier
and um i definitely suffered a bit at
the beginning that imposter syndrome but
i think just more the more you have the
more client calls you have i think the
easier it becomes yeah fair enough so
katie why don't we obviously talking
about we're talking about i guess a bit
about it there but i guess any other
challenges that you've had to work
through in the past year
yeah i think it is similar but i think
it is just like the candidate control i
think that's a big
challenge that i've had in recruitment
um
obviously
there's only so much you can do to
persuade someone to just for example
take an offer so
it is hard and and it is you do get
really invested into it don't you
emotionally yeah um
and yeah i think that's definitely the
biggest challenge i've faced if i've had
say offers rejected
so like well as in also like just i
guess just trying to like not go home
and like think about that until you go
sleep as well as part of that yeah
exactly
fair and then i guess jamie for you then
i know we're just speaking a bit about a
challenge but i guess what i'm
interested in is i'm sure
this is maybe how you would describe it
now or you may have heard it be
described but most people would say
like your first year first two years in
recruitment will be probably one of the
hardest
so just trying to paint a real picture
of the challenges that people can expect
so any other challenges that you've
maybe had to work through or maybe you
even support some of your team with now
yeah i mean we've not been short of
challenges to be fair
there's been obviously a the pandemic to
work through in our first year you know
operating as a business
um and that and trying to learn
recruitment at the same time was you
know a couple of things to juggle um and
i think just like getting the uh right
getting the brand name out there as well
i mean you know there's i think over 40
000 recruitment businesses in the uk you
know what there's a lot
yeah what makes you guys different to
anyone else that's emailing us and i can
imagine these people get hundreds of the
same types of emails every day so yeah i
think i think the challenge is just
really standing out um and
yeah believing in what we're selling as
i said before uh they've been kind of
the key ones and then sort of internally
a challenge for me
um
through growing into more of the
leadership type positions has been you
know
learning
the switch between um you know just
recruiting day in day out which is what
i did every day for you know the first
year to
to now stripping that back and putting
my success in other people's hands uh
that that's something that i had never
experienced before in my life like
basically relying on others for my own
success and yeah i mean it's something
i'm still adapting to but it's uh you
know it's super exciting stuff and we've
got great people like katie under me
that's making my job a bit easier
yeah yeah just talk just talk to us a
bit looks like i'm just interested
because obviously i would say most
ambitious
young professionals who want to get into
recruitment will say
look jamie i want to join your team
because i want to progress i want to get
to the position that you are whatever so
i guess you're now obviously in that i
know you're still learning a lot and
everything as you said but like you've
got you're obviously on that journey
where you're like right i am on the
right track i've progressed so far this
is why i wanted to join the industry
so like again has there been i don't
know have you has there been imposter
syndrome show up if you're now leading
the team or i don't know how have you
actually because you're basically what
you just said is you're doing a lot of
things for the first time or continuing
these yeah like how are you working
through that
how are you making sure that doesn't get
the best of you
yeah i'm just always
not afraid to ask questions i think um
you know it's a journey where you're ex
you're expected to to pick things up
quickly if you want to do well um you
know so it's always asking and trying to
improve your skill set sort of day and
day something that
um you know i've always tried to do
especially from you know we've got great
directors in the storm too and i'd love
like they've been there done that and
you know asking them you know how to do
it what's their opinions and things has
really helped me massively and also
kind of always renewing my belief system
i think you know if you're
if you set my you know i believe your
beliefs and i want to achieve
just be a manager and then you stop
there then you you probably will only
hit that whereas yeah yeah i think i
think with the ambition side of things
it is super important to keep sort of
editing your belief system as your your
skill set grows and that's what's kind
of enabled me to keep kind of spurring
on and trying to hit the the hit the
next targets yeah i really like that
really in your belief system so okay so
katy what i want to find out from you
then is i guess like knowing what you
know now
like
like what advice would you give
to people who graduated this year
considering recruitment or may have had
a similar conversation like you did with
a friend
what advice would you give them to i
guess just have the best possible chance
of
um making it as much of a success it can
be in in those first 12 months
yeah i think really it's just about
working really hard and i guess onto
your point previously about challenges i
think one of the biggest challenges of
with recruitment is that like the hours
can be long sometimes because
and you may have friends who are a lot
of my friends work nine to five and you
have to make sacrifices don't you but i
think
i i don't work as long as i used to and
i do definitely you know reaping the
rewards um
becoming like a manager within first
seven eight months and get your own team
it's just things that you can't really
you can't really get if you if you don't
really put in the hours at the beginning
yeah for sure what so for you then it
would just be like just commit basically
and really apply yeah yeah exactly just
put everything into it
so on this then if you don't mind me
asking
so just a lot because a lot of i think a
lot of people obviously are
i don't know i don't want to say worried
but like apprehensive maybe like talk to
us about so when you say you've had to
like really put the work in what talk to
us about a typical day then when would
you start when do you finish typically i
know it's very typically
yeah it has changed a lot over the last
few months as i've moved into management
because um
you have your own clients and everything
but at the beginning i i've always sort
of started around eight half eight and
then finish around
a half six seven but then
i work the american market so there's a
lot of times when i used to take calls
like 9 10 p.m yeah yeah but i don't do
that anymore and at the end of the day
yeah you if you're working in a
different time zone you sometimes have
to yeah so that's a big factor isn't it
tonight yeah
yeah fair enough
um okay so really apply yourself cool
yeah jamie what what about you what
would you say to obviously you've you've
um you're obviously two years down the
track now knowing what you know what
would you what would your advice be to
people entering the recruitment industry
make a success of it yeah recruit
recruitment i'd say is like playing a
piano at start you you learn lots of
like individual keys and uh
not many of them join up but then
you know as
as you get this in the swing of things
it all starts oh you know
your head starts connecting with your
hands and all starts making you know it
starts paying off for you great analogy
uh yeah
i think
outside of that you know just be be kind
of open-minded and and get stuck in as
is the most important thing like the the
grads we've seen the best of the ones
that are just so open to learn and ask
lots of questions when they start and
are just really keen to to get the ball
rolling um the the ones we see kind of
slower starters are the ones that are
still in kind of uni mode when you enter
the the recruitment life like it is
is a bit of a jump going from uni to
to recruitment what's uni mode waking up
a lot 1pm
[Laughter]
just kind of going through the motions
but i think it's i think
it's one of these uh jobs where
as i said before it's you get out what
you put into it um yeah so you can
actually see you know we've had people
doing deals in the first sort of
four six four to six weeks but then
there'll be other people that won't do
them for you know four or five months
and that's purely because there's ones
that are just super super hungry to go
and get it and get stuck in the early
days
yeah
okay so i just wanted to ask you both
this and um
hopefully you can share something or
so i guess on sort of katie's point i'll
come back to you jamie first on this
like
obviously with us i think something that
i've i've definitely seen
let me know if you disagree or agree but
i do feel like i'm sure you've sort of
come to realize that there definitely
can be a quite high um turnover rate in
the recruitment industry right and i do
feel like
part of that although it will be a
complex thing there'll be so many
different factors i do think part of
that for sure is
obviously um people putting in the work
but and then like building unsustainable
habits and burning out or just yeah just
i guess just working too hard trying to
like just work every under out of the
sun and three months down the line
they're just like i can't do this
forever
so i guess the question is is like
knowing that you have to absolutely
apply yourself
what what were you mindful of or what
did you make sure you did personally to
make sure that you didn't burn out out
of interest or was that even something
you was thinking about
yeah i think um
you have to take your holidays don't you
i think
especially at storm two they really say
you know you just take every single day
of your holiday and
i think as long as you take your holiday
and you have a nice week off then i
think you know you can recover
another thing that i've been doing more
recently is saying
on my phone my app so i won't check my
emails or things like that because
on weekends i wouldn't work weekends i
think you just do need to step away from
it that is the most important thing
yeah so mate just being really
intentional with
space that you give yourself that isn't
like i'll just check this email here
exactly yeah make sure you take your
holiday
yeah yeah definitely
yeah fair enough what about you jamie
anything that you was aware of or maybe
you try and
you sort of
encourage your team to do to maybe avoid
this
yeah i mean to be honest the the leaders
storm tour are really really good when
it comes to personal wellness uh
something they look out for i think they
each of them have been in sort of cowboy
type environments where
um there isn't the emphasis on the
mental well-being especially when we're
working from home like uh they would
strongly encourage you to take um kind
of as kitty said any holidays when
required we have you know a personal
wellness day kind of once a quarter
things like that just to make sure
everyone's recharging the batteries
and then to be honest the working hours
uh especially well for us anyway there's
no expectation to work you know
past nine of what in between nine and
six past past that time um and you know
we we get you know filler for lunch and
everyone's encouraged to kind of go to
the gym or go a walk at least and
that's something i encourage my team to
do as well because i just feel and
anyone that does it is just feel you
know the days split up really nicely and
everyone's feeling refreshed
yeah i think i think that's the thing
isn't it is like that expectation piece
isn't it because i think
what can also really encourage that
feeling of
burnout or or just those decisions is
that oh like if i don't stay until this
time jamie's not gonna be happy do you
know what i mean if you've got people
feeling like that then it's it's
you're in trouble
or if you're feeling like that that
isn't that isn't fair
really do you know what i mean
so i think that's such an important
point
um
so
what i'd love to find out from both of
you okay i'll come to you first
this is i guess just
obviously most most recruitment but it
may or may not have i've sort of got a
grasp of this but i saw a post
uh this week actually where
there was like some linkedin stats
around like it there's this is the sort
of um i can't remember what country it
was in but it was like the most amount
of recruitment jobs posted
like pre-covered levels basically in
terms of recruitment vacancies
so there'll be a lot of recruiting
agencies that either listen to this or
out there that want to hire people like
both of you young ambitious driven
people
um but what i want to find out from both
of you is like
what type of companies
like what what would that what actually
excites
young people today in your in your
opinion in terms of like the types of
companies that people are actually
really motivated to work for or get
excited by is it the i b for incentives
is it being able to afford a rolex you
know i mean like what i don't know what
what what's your opinion on things that
you feel like actually connect with the
young people of today out of interest
yeah i think um just having a lot of
autonomy in your in your role that's
something that really appeals to me and
i like jamie said i don't think
leadership at storm 2 are controlling at
all they as long as you get the work
done but it's yeah that's absolutely
fine and i think for me the opportunity
for international travel is probably
like like the biggest excitement for me
yeah
so i've as i said i've been here for
nine months or
nearly a year now i think and we've
already got like trip to singapore
pending trip skiing potentially the
opportunity to move to new york next
year so i think things like that
really do appeal to me
yeah interesting jamie what about you
what
what resonates with young people in your
opinion
yeah i mean pretty similar i don't think
anyone's going to turn down a holiday to
ibiza or you know trip over to the
states um but yeah i think as i said
earlier the the thing that really got me
was when speaking to the different
founders was you know who had the most
ambitious vision for the business um and
you know where you could go internally
like it was mapped out very clearly to
me where you know the potential for
growth internally for me which was such
an important factor um yeah i mean the
the commission structure and things she
is very very good at storm two but i
mean there you know a lot a lot of
companies have commission in place so
you have to look past that and and the
um
yeah the real selling points for me
where where does this con company want
to go if i come in here and do really
well where will i you know wherever
yeah
yeah and that was that was super clear
and also the thing that we we haven't
mentioned is we have the you know
starting to only hire as grads so we
have a team of people that are all very
very similarly
motivated yeah i mean i've met some of
my you know i
can confidently say that we friends for
life um
and you know i look forward to going to
the office every day just to see all the
all the smiling faces because we all do
get on really well and it's a good you
know a good company called it's great
yeah camaraderie and everything yeah
that's awesome so a couple of final
questions then before we uh finish so i
guess gemini come back to you i guess
i'm just interested to get your thoughts
on this so practical advice for
people who graduating this year or
trying to enter the workforce for the
sort of first time from what i
understood about storm 2 outside looking
in obviously they were trying to hire a
lot of people i'm sure you both of you
would have been applying when loads of
other people applying at the same time
would have been competitive so i guess
the question i have for both of you um
is like what like knowing what you know
now supporting people with their sort of
career and all the context you have now
like what would be your sort of best
advice for people like you who may have
just been graduating to stand out and
and sort of stand out amongst the
competition and the amount of people
that will be applying for similar jobs
you have interest yeah i think i think
in in terms of the interviews himself
like show your ambition and your key
drivers that's something that we
certainly look out for we want people
that are going to come in and and really
be hungry to succeed that that's an
important one
and in terms of resilience i mean
recruitment's something that it's a bit
of an emotional rollercoaster at times
and yeah you know not not everyone
is cut out and i i think that's why the
attrition rate is pretty high but um
you know if you can talk about times
where you have gone through adversity
and come out the other side um you're
stronger i think that's something that
that sets really well with the founders
of these businesses uh and also you know
it sounds trouble but turn up looking
tidy to an interview because uh the
number of people we've said said no to
just because looks like they just rolled
off their couch as uh another one
[Music]
okay what about you what would be your
tips for
people that are trying to enter the
workforce this year i think yeah i think
really just just maybe um
outside of work just talking about what
you are passionate about obviously
it's no secret that the money is a huge
driver for people in recruitment is it
um
and if you have a passion if you have
something that you do want to spend your
money on whether it be holidays or i
don't know like louis vuitton bags or
something i think if you can speak about
that it does show that you will be
motivated to work really hard
fair enough
final question
i'll come to you first katie so i guess
final question just is obviously like
both of you
shared really obviously a lot of people
end up in recruitment
quite accidentally right so i i do
really feel like
recruitment should be more of a career
choice for sure um because of loads of
different things that you shared with us
today on what it can support you have
helped you with give you professionally
so
final question really is like why
why do you think
people should actually be considering
recruitment as a career choice rather
than being an accident of interest from
your point of view
i think
number one would probably be career
progression um i think there's not a lot
of companies where grads can join and
you can be like jc for example could be
director in a few months there's not a
lot of companies where you can be two or
three years out of uni and be a director
of a company so i think that would be
the number one reason
progression is it's real it isn't a fad
plot if you can achieve it yeah yeah not
with storm 2 definitely not yeah love
that jc then final final point why why
should people consider recruitment as a
career rather than a career choice
rather than accident
yeah definitely the the growth
opportunities is a huge thing um
and in terms of the one the one fear i
had of coming out of uni was i didn't
want to be a small cog and a big wheel
and you know spend spend 15 years of my
life trying to
get to somewhere that has you know just
a bit of influence where you know the
reality is it took um you know about 18
months to get in a position where we're
making
significant business decisions every day
leading teams uh you know pushing for us
uh to to the sort of director level and
and and the international opportunities
as is something like
as a reality we were you know in talks
with it just now about moving abroad and
opening up our own offices and things
like that so yeah the growth thing's
huge um yeah money money is
important i mean the ability to pay off
your student debt and
two years after after uni is um you know
it is possible doing this career choice
and also just like
personal happiness like i i as i said
before i'm i'm happy turning up to work
every day you know i share and share i
share a flat with three other guys from
from school and a couple of them doing
accounting and other other degrees and i
can tell you they're hating life
compared to me uh you know
yeah there's uh there's there's plenty
of plenty of options for for sure and i
think it should be seriously considered
as a career because it's yeah
it's a great job and we katie and i have
lots of fun
i love it jamie kate has been an
absolute pleasure thank you so much for
uh getting involved with the series
thank you yeah thanks for having us